bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
justin qui représente la société jagger
et lewis est ce que tu peux nous
expliquer ce qui revient à lewis et
qu'est ce que vous apportez pour nos
animaux de compagnie pour nos t-shirts
c'était pas ici donc c'est un
on va mettre du sien et qui va nous
permettre de relever
évidemment les comportements anormaux
c'est vraiment de
les variations qu'il peut y avoir des
comportements chez le chien
et
ar c'est gratis et ai découvert qu il
la scion et un changement
du chat on en rit
checkez notification sur bonal de bord
les fêtes
sur l'autre
éventuellement lainesse il ya un souci
aussi importante
on envoie des conseils également que moi
travail
alors c'est quoi un comportement anormal
chez en chine par exemple le sublimant
le chien
rate jamais parce qu'on a observé deux
chiffres
et ce matin il s'est gratté 3 3 heures
comme ça en permanence sur glace
vérifiez qu'il peut dire par exemple
marquant même dermato donc apparaître
en fait
avoir assez dans la journée alors
d'aller d'une
peut-être en chine
tu les as
on ne vole pas
je mettrai ça je mettrai on ne vole pas
on ouvre le bal ou non le bar au caire
nous sommes là bas on finit on arrive à
occuper donc des comportements anormaux
se gratter pas voir toutes les choses
comme ça donc ça vous envoie des infos
et vous voudriez vous pourrez agir en
tant que maître du chien voilà pour
adapter effectivement en fait voilà on
mais on vous donne un peu les clés pour
comprendre le comportement de votre
chien
très intéressant que vous n'êtes pas
tout le temps avec votre chien notamment
quand on travaille de chez intel a misé
et là on peut suivre
alors ce qu'il a fait et s'il est un
comportement normal dans la journée
si les roches nils il est gardé par
quelque bout qu'on est en attente c'est
de mieux apprendre à connaître
miracle génial elle vient d'où l'idée du
coût de ce type alors c'est alexandre
nature qui est un chien
vacances et le chien s'est retourné
l'estomac
et bhl heureusement bénévoles tout de
suite avec au chant allait pas bien et
ce comportement là d'anormal chercheurs
j'ai tout fait
avec ça
m
et pourquoi pas découvrir
les modernités connaître
justement à prendre avec vous
carrément on va c'est super intéressant
alors du coup est ce que c'est un
produit qui est déjà disponible sur le
marché vous avez en est que la scène
depuis sept ans
amis qu'on a monté le projet la cellule
est commercialisé ont contactés
ont sans cesse améliorer sans cesse et
ces informations
ça va pour semer chien l'application est
marche sur ios et android
en anglais il est présent aussi chez
d'autres distributeurs ouvrir 200 hôtels
en france on peut la st cyp roquettes
landes
j'étais chez orange je sais moi ni mot
et puis bientôt on pourra l'acheter
aussi
ça veut dire que c'est possible qu'ils
se portent bien à une belle évolution
développement c'est le début après
devant eux
voilà c est horrible mais on est fier de
ce qu'on dise qu'on nous présente et on
espère que ça va
et en prenant toutes leurs aventures
génial bon bah écoute merci beaucoup je
vous invite à laisser des commentaires
pour me dire si vous avez un chien
effectivement ce type au logis de
collier pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que vous connaissez déjà le côté
du birger d'anévrisme arkema tout ça en
commentaire parce que ça ces déçus qui
sont si super intéressant vous invite
comme d'habitude a mené ses jolies
pousse à vous abonner
on reste connectés parce qu'on va parler
toujours plus d'entreprises françaises
innovantes
merci beaucoup at rome merci à bientôt
[Musique]